en fait en comment ça j'ai pas compris
c'est qui Didi c'est les
ex possibles héritiers du royaume qui
son en disgrâce aujourd'hui parce qu'ils
sont fâchés avec le le frère aîné qui
lui régent tout avec le roi Charles
voilà couple maudit un peu alors
certains disent qu'il sea proche de la
séparation truc de ouf par qu'il y a
vraiment de l'eau dans le
gaz petit récap et dans un instant
Bertrand des KERS nous dira tous sachez
que Bertrand des KERS est très très
affecté par cette nouvelle
ou il est au bout de sa vie c'était tout
à l'heure
ça là c'était
avant là ça all encore bien mais
maintenant je peux vous dire est-ce que
je peux voir juste montrer le moi juste
[Rires]
Mo il est vraiment pas biene le pvre
regardez
leap c'est la nouvelle qui agite la
planète people et le
RoyaumeUni
alors que Méan aurait récemment été
aperçu sans son alliance et que le
couple entame des déplacements séparés
le prince qui se ferait parfois la mal
dans un hôtel pour la fuir se montrerait
de plus en plus stressé et il y a
quelques mois megéan avait même refusé
d'embrasser son mari devant une foule de
spectateurs lors d'un match de basket
une preuve irréfutable pour beaucoup que
le couple bat de l'aile alors y
aurait-il de l'eau dans le gaz entre
megéan et Harry toutes les information
de Bertrand des KERS ce soir dans
TPMP merci Bertrand
Bertrand des Ker Bertrand des Ker qui va
nous en dire un petit peu plus sur le
couple Harry et Méan déjà est-ce que le
roi Charles était content de sa visite à
palame il est bien
rentré il est non il est content il
s'est dit content ils se sont dit le roi
et camia ravis des nombreux cadeaux qui
leur ont étést eu qu'est-ce qu'ils ont
eu oh ils ont reçu énormément c la liste
est
incomenurable pass pourquoi ils ont pas
passé les fêtes de Kipour et de
souscotte ici ah les Kipour et souscotte
bah voilà ils l'ont fait à
Londres préfér préfér rentrer au ont
comme cadeau des énorme énorme énorme
des lampes une lampe de luxe elle un sac
une petite pochette offerte par Louis
Vitton la maison luoui jiton absolument
euh des euh des comment dire elle adore
la lecture donc elle a reçu une édition
des comptes de Charles perraot une
édition originale du 18e siècle
Cendrillon plutôt Cendrillon Charles per
chaboté le oui le chatoté oui Péro ça le
chatoté c'est Péro bien sûr c'est P bien
sûr c'était surtout Cendrillon je pense
je te dis c'est pas Pierro mon oncle
c'est Perro donc voilà beaucoup beaucoup
de cadeaux du vas du vas ils ont reçu du
V ça picole les deux là ça Picol ils
aiment bien ils aiment bien ouis c'est
vrai il sont plutôt elle elle est plutôt
tu as déjà vu Charles un peu torché ou
pas du tout Charles un peu torché non on
n pas vraiment des photos de Charles
torché ouis ça boit avec cam Camilla et
et alors non seulement ça boit mais
alors on dit que dans une des
Rolls-Royce vous savez qu' une voiture
officielle il y a un système qui a été
mis au point où entre les deux passagers
il y a vous savez un petit un petittit
petit coffret comme ça et alors voilà
sous ellisabeth i c'était un poudrier
qu'il y avait dans ce petit coffret pour
que la reine puisse se repoudrer avant
de sortir de voiture et désormais ce
serait une bouteille de
Jean Cania parce qu'elle aime bien elle
aime bien de jein je je jein de jein
Jean non je les Anglais ils aiment le
jein la plus chaude des boissons froides
voilà non du jean elle boit du jean
comme ça celle super fort non elle boit
pas du jean comme ça mais voilà il y
aurait à sa disposition une bouteille
pas réfrigéré qui elle boit comme ça non
elle ne pas ou elle boitfin elle ne boit
pas on peut pas dire que Gal est une
alcoolique mais c'est vrai qu'elle aime
bien elle aime bien boire son petit
frère elle boit un petit verre tous les
soirs je connais il me l'a dit char vous
l'a dit quand exactement il m'a dit
quand on était ensemble vous étiez
ensemble passé par ensemble en
dernier je jure je suis passé parce que
P passe avec un plateau je passe
audessus de lui comme ça je te jure ETM
je fait tout et c'est une grande
amatrice de va parce que son père on le
rappelle il était négociant
en euh dis-moi est-ce que tu peux nous
parler de Harry et Méan Harry et Mégane
donc Harry on le rappelle c'est le fils
de char là le deuxième fils voilà qu'on
voit et alors je pense que la l'idée du
jour c'est problème problème au sein du
couple il y aurait-il de l'eau dans le
gaz entre Harry et Méan en effet on est
paraît alors dis la vérité paraît qu'ils
n'ont plus de relation sexuelle je ne
suis pas dans la chambre à coucher moi
tu toi qui l'as dit aux équipes arrête
un peu tu as dit k plus il k plus ouais
il kenerait moi en tout cas ce qui ne k
plus du tout je n'irai pas jusque là il
paraît qu'il kerait moi oui comment tu
sais toi bah il y a quand même des
signes avantcourur qui nous laissent
présager que elle est apparue plusieurs
fois sans son alliance voilà c'est une
première
PIST peut-être elle a fait du bowling
peut-être elle a fait du bowling oui en
effet il voyage de plus en plus seul on
sait que cet été il s'est rendu une fois
au Japon et une fois en Afrique du Sud
il était seul elle ne l'accompagnait pas
ce qui est quand même assez rare iciil a
il a fauté bah on sait pas pourquoi il a
demandé en effet pour pour partir dans
un des voyages il a emmené son
fils une meuf non je n'iris pas jusque
là mais il a a par d'une certaine Daniel
Morau Ahou on l'aurait vu du côté de
Royan cet été celui-là non non non il a
pas de meuf on on ne sait pas si'il a
meu est-ce qu'il pourrait lui est-ce
qu'il pourrait avoir une autre meuf où
il se fait cramer direct non non je
pense que vraiment il se ferait comme tu
dis
cramer cramé direct oui mais mais mais
mais puisque tu me me me donnes une très
belle perche merci on dit aussi dans ce
qu'on dit que il a il lourait à l'année
un genre de cottage quoi un genre de de
petit de
petitar garceniè
voilàà à un 4 4 parce é très luxueux et
où en effet il aurait il aurait besoin
de son indépendance alors qu'on rappelle
quand même que la fameuse villa privée
de montite qui a été acheté 15 millions
de dollars en 2020 c'est énorme he les
chambres elles sont par dizaines et il y
a une maison d'invité d'ailleurs au ça
de c'est un peu ça qui nous in qui
l'invite celui-là qui l'invite bah alors
on sait pas s'il reçoit quelqu'unou pas
c'est très difficile de dire ça il
faudrait pouvoir en permanence pouvoir
contrôler qui rentre et qui sort donc ça
je ne suis pas en mesure de pouvoir
donner cette info mais en tout cas le
fait que déjà il aurait loué quelque
chose alors on sa pas V si c'est à si
c'est régulier ou pas c'est quand même
très interpellant et autre chose alors
là vraiment plus interpellante je trouve
encore c'est que tu sais il y a quelque
chose qui est très important pour lui
c'est les Invictus Games vous savez
c'est ce qu'il a créé c'est ce
rendez-vous
paral rendev ou les handicapés en
rendez-vous un peu de G pour handicaper
ça lui tient vraiment à cœur ça a été
créé sous Elisabeth I avec Elisabeth 2
bien cette grande réception cette grande
manifestation avait lieu le 9 septembre
il sa très bien que les caméras du monde
entier sont un peu là c'est un peu
tu l'impression que tu vas trop vite
tu elle n'était pas là non il était où
il était seul à dueldorf à dueldorf
c'était en Allemagne il est pas a qu'une
allemande celui-ci Birgit troudle non s
rigoler quoi c'est chelou qu'est-ce
qu'il faisait du là-bas donc voilà il
ouvrait les Invictus Games non mais à
dendorf qu'est-ce qu'il faisit les
Invictus Games se sont cette année se
sont fait à dendorf l'année dernière
c'était Amsterdam vous savez il voyage
mais tu as dit qu'il était pas allé si
se lui mais pas elle lui mais pas elle
elle est arriv 4 jours plus
tard dis elle gardait les enfants alors
peut-être peut-être qu'elle gardait les
enfants il a y
a j'imine qu'elle a des nan absolument
c'est très étonnant et vraiment la vraie
info qui nous interpelle nous plus que
le fait qu'elle porte pas all la vérité
tu tu sais des choses balance alle
vas très bien ce qui se passe si tu dis
qu'il a de l'eau dans le gaz c'est qu' y
a deau dans le G je t'avou allez
balançons tout et nous on est allez
balance on est alerté
[Applaudissements]
voilàance balance qui nous interpelle
surtout surtout c'est c'est l'entourage
de laiss parler va tout balancer dans
l'entourage d' Megan on dit pas
grand-chose voilà mais quand on va
creuser du côté de Pra Winfrey vous
savez la si grande copine la papesse de
la révélation qui a accouché Mégane et
toutes les révélations qu' la oui en
tout cas tout ce qu'elle avait à dire
c'est une métaphore oui et bien quand on
creuse un peu dans l'entourage de pr la
famille du GFR oh non du du GFR mais non
regarde voilà céitpr non pas je pense
AUC parenté même si on remonte très très
loin et tout ça pour dire que quand on
creuse dans l'entourage de Prat on
apprend qu'il y a de plus en plus de
tension en effet entre Harry et Mégane
et que vous savez en juin dernier on a
beaucoup parlé de cette poursuite dans
les rues de New yor en voiture où ils
auraient été
poursuiv il aur ét ils auraient été
poursuiv par des Paparadis oui en effet
et là il y a eu un clash énorme
racon-ons dans l'entourage de Prin où
elle Mégane a dit à RIM tu fais de ma
vie tu as fait de ma vie un bordel un
merdier je ne savais pas qu'épouser un
prince me mettrait à jour dans une
situation d'épouser le prince de et bien
voilà et c'est ce qu'il lui a dit lui a
dit M ma petite chérie tu le savais très
bien dans la situation dans
laquelle personne ne t'a mis un fusil
sur la temp tu as accepté ce
mariage cacahuè tot totalz balance tout
encore
balance balance tout balance tout sur ma
vie balance c'est déjà pas mal c'est
surtout depuis depuis le MO Jo il aurait
eu un gros gros froid ah qu'est-ce a eu
qu'est-ce qu'il y a eu ce que j'ai
raconter là ouis donc elle lui a dit
ouais mais elle en a j'en ai marre j'en
ai marre un peu de la vie que tu me fais
mener lui lui a répondu mais tu savais
très bien là où tu metttais les il peut
divorcer un prince il peut divorcer oui
oui absolument déjà Pras peut divorcer
il pourrait mais il pourrait oui il
pourrait lui dire rentre chez toi elle
elle peut lui dire t arrête bah oui
c'est plutôt elle qui lui dirait rentre
chez toi elle elle veut plus non non je
ne dis pas du tout qu'ils veulent plus
honnêtement Cyril tu sais ce que je
pense tuens ils sont pas du tout au bord
de la sépar arrête un mytho je le sais
tu sais pourquoi Harry a besoin de et
Megan a besoin de Harry ensemble il ne
forment plus c'est le couple qui est
bonne qui est bol c'est le couple qui
fait qu' pas si bien sû que si je t'ass
Harry est devenu un peu sexy parce qu'il
y a Megan Megan est devenu intéressante
parce qu'il y a Harry si tu les
dispatches ce n elle va rebondir Méan
rest elle va rebondir Méan oui mais pour
moi elle n'est pas prête à le jarté pas
maintenant donc tu penses que c'est un
mariage pas intérêt que tu es en train
de dire non je ne dis
pas non non non non non je pense que
elle a vu Harry qui passer comme le
dernier tra en som en se disant si si si
alors vous savez très bien je naime pas
Méan mais si je pense vraiment qu'elle a
elle a vu en tout cas l'intérê mais je
ne dis pas qu'elle n'en est pas
amoureuse elle a compris en tout cas que
les caméras du monde entier enfin
allaient être posé sur elle qui adore ça
on rappelle quand même qu'elle était
actrice vous ne devenez pas actrice
lorsque vous n'aimez pas la lumière des
médias
et alors on aurait vu Méan tu me dis si
c'est faux on l'aurait vu se balader
avec un patch
antistress ça c inf faut tu l'avais pas
si c'est vrai alors plus de bag et un
patch Aness qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
STR ça veut dire qu'elle sera un peu
stress et donc qu'est-ce qu'elle a mis
bah pantistess pourquoi bah pour
déstresser l'excéd pourquoi elle stresse
pourquoi elle stresse c'est le
commissariat parce qu'il l'énerve c'est
vrai qu'il paraît qu'il l'énerve en même
temps lui lui il a tout le temps les
mains moies en permanence et lui aussi
il multiplie il multiplie les signes lui
aussi de main moi comme ça je grat les y
ou quoi il est tout c'est élégant nonman
élégant je l'adore c'est élégant alors
qu'est-ce qu'il fait bah il est énervé
il est stressé et là en effet il y avait
une grande réception mondaine qui avait
lieu à losangeles lorsqu'ils sont
rentrés ENF de dusüseldorf chez Kevin
kner et il était Kevin Kevin Kevin kcas
oui Kin
que oui merci bodyard oui voilà il a
fait une fête Kevin oui il il a remis un
prix il a invité des amis à lui une
réception très très chiic il y avait qui
oh ben il y avait avait tout le
monde il pas
Brach il y avait l'entourage l'entourage
de Haran vous savez tout l'entourage un
peu
América
cl
Clint je sais pas qui sa moi tu connais
pas Clint non attends quoi
non Bertrand vous êtes extraordinaire
mais vous avez un seul défaut c'est que
vous avez toujours détesté ce couple on
a l'impression que vous voulez depuis le
début qu'il se sépare moi je les adore
je suis sûr qu'ils s'adorent évidemment
ils ont beaucoup de pression on a
presque l'impression que la royauté a
envie qu'ils se sépare pour prouver
qu'ils avaient raison est-ce que vous
vous êtes pas un peu sous emprise de
cette royauté tu es sous emprise un
alors moi j'ai tenté en tout cas tenté
hein euh de ici d'apporter des faits
donc en effet voilà la bague en effet le
fait qu'elle est énerveuse le fait
qu'elle est sous patch quand même c'est
quand même pas un NA le fait qu'il se
déplace elle soit
ainten alors pour revenir sur votre
question elle a pas besoin non elle fait
pas manger elle fait
pasam tout ça rien c'est vrai que en
tout cas voilà les ceux qui supportent
davantage le CL wi verrait en effet une
erreur de parcours qui aurait été
formulée par Harry mais on ne souhaite
pas sa séparation je suis le premier à
dire que il renouvelle la monarchie
Harry Megan ne serait pas là je ser pas
devant vous en train de vous parler de
la famille royale elle aim les banatag
la
rép elle elle aime le Maou le Maou c'est
une spécialité ah non mais vous savez
mais pas du tout non non non Méan c'est
ta c'est c'est régime permanent c'est
légumes c'est le café que l'on boit à la
paille le café au
soja merus non jamais jamais
jamais mer jamais de mer non jamais de
merg Sand mer rien che dis che che
che oui oui Beran j'ai une question
est-ce qu' Harry devient pas encombrant
pour Mégane dont on dit qu'elle veut se
lancer en politique aux États-Unis
sénatrice de Californie puis
éventuellement la Maison Blanche est-ce
qu'il faut pas le virer pour ça ça Mo
j'y crois vraiment ça fait plusieurs
mois que je dis ici qu'elle veut faire
de la politique Mégane et qu'elle veut
devenir sénatrice alors pourquoi est-ce
qu'elle le virerait non je je pense
vraiment que c'est l'offre qui a
rencontré la demande ils ont besoin l'un
de l'autre je maintenant ce que je crois
c'est que de son côté à lui il y a une
part de souffrance quand on connaitt un
peu har je vous assure que je le suis
quand même depuis longtemps on a vu une
évolution quand même bah il est triste
il est triste parce que il a tout perdu
Harry il a perdu son pays il a perdu son
éducation il a perdu ses amis il a perdu
son domicile on rappelle que depuis
qu'on lui a repris flmore cottage il n'a
même plus piétateur mais maintenant il
est il est exilé améric ce sont les
exilés de Buckingham ils nont pour rien
depuis qu'on a retiré flocm cottage il y
a un petit un autre pavillon mais c'est
une bicque
je vous
assureth voilà on balance Elizabeth 2
elle a fait
donner cotage et York cottage alors il
AR reste York cottage mais York cottage
quand vous mettez les pieds à York
cottage c'est c'est un débarras en
réalité où tous les membres de la
famille royale m entrepos des vieux
mbles horribles du mobilier qui ne
veulent plus donc voilà il reste encore
plus ou moins petit pié c'est vrai qu'il
est à l'hôtel qu'il est à ah oui bah oui
c'esté bravo
alors ça c'est
excitant le 7 septembre il était de
retour à Londres parce qu'il devait
voilà euh euh rendre tri et bien il n'a
pas pu être logé dans une des résidences
de la couronne alors qu'il en a fait la
demande à CLI tu sais CLI le copain c le
secrétaire du roi et bien le secrétaire
du roi a répondu non voilà vous faites
votre demande trop tard vous n'avez pas
la jouissance d'une propriété de la
couronne alors que le par sur quand même
est incroyable et tu as raison
excuse-moi je suis un peu long il a dû
dormir à l'hôel comment je sais tout
voilà bravo voilà on se retrouve dans un
instant les ché à tout de
suite